You know, we've been talking about the possibility
that on Election Day, Donald Trump will try
to use federal troops to intimidate voters
at polling places.
And it turns out that Trump may not even have
to because his own supporters are showing
up at early voting sites and already intimidating
voters.
We're seeing a big advantage for Democrats
in terms of absentee ballots and in terms
of early voting.
And the Trump lists are showing up and doing
what they can to intimidate voters.
Virginia had its first week of early voting
groups of Trump supporters were showing up,
including in northern Virginia, blocking the
path to the location.
This was a disproportionately Democratic area
of Virginia chanting four more years.
It actually led to county election officials
having to provide escorts for voters to get
past the protesters.
Groups of Trump supporters were chanting four
more years and doing all sorts of other stuff.
We have video.
This was captured by Maryland photographer
Anthony Tilghman.
And you'll see the crowd carrying Trump signs,
flags, chanting right outside the building,
making it difficult to get in and out.
Now, remember, the legality of this is unclear
because electioneering at polling places isn't
allowed.
What counts as being at the polling place
depends on the state.
In Virginia, my understanding is that it's
within 40 feet of the front doors.
It certainly seems as though in this video,
the protesters are within 40 feet of the front
doors.
So as you can see, trumpet's creating a blockade,
chanting, blocking the path, and now there
are people who are saying, including the Virginia
Republican Party, which I'll get to.
There are people saying this is an intimidation.
Only the most triggered snowflake could consider
this intimidation.
Anybody can just walk by.
Guys, this is not how elections are supposed
to happen.
There is not supposed to be electioneering
at polling places.
If you are just to pick something for a 70
year old woman showing up to vote for Biden,
and you have to weave your way through a crowd
of dozens of Trump trumpets by the front door
chanting, blocking the path, holding signs,
screaming.
That is not how elections are supposed to
happen in the United States.
There are election officials in Fairfax County,
Virginia, and who are admitting that voters
and even some of the poll workers felt intimidated
by this crowd.
And again, they required escorts to get people
in and out of the building.
And again, it's illegal in Virginia.
You can't be within 40 feet of the precincts
in Virginia.
Now, the Virginia Republican Party just mocked
the entire thing.
The New York Times put out a story about this
and the Virginia Republican Party tweeted
the story with the message.
Quick, someone called the whammed billons,
which is just, you know, the height of maturity.
And interestingly, some of the voters who
were in line to vote were asked, why are you
standing in such a long line to vote in person?
You could vote by mail.
You're standing in line to vote early in person.
And voter said, we don't trust the mail.
Take a look at this report from CNN.
I just got to step out here so you can see
just how far back this line goes.
I mean, it's about two football fields here.
And keep in mind, this is a huge government
building in Fairfax, Virginia, the biggest
county here, and they're at capacity inside
of the building.
They're trying to keep people here outside
socially distant.
But as you can see, it is difficult, particularly
given the fact that this slide is so enormous.
And once they actually get inside of the building,
there is still at least an hour and a half
wait.
Now, we have talked to several of these voters
about why it is that they chose to show up
early.
Many of them think they knew it was going
to be a very big election, that it was critical
that there was going to be a lot of interest.
They wanted to be one of the first people
to cast their ballot.
But we also heard about mistrust of the postal
service.
Take a listen to this program on trust, the
real that's out of here all day.
So this gets me to the one good thing that
I am seeing in terms of enthusiasm.
It seems to be high.
I've been using this phrase for a couple of
months.
People might be willing to crawl over broken
glass to vote.
It seems people are willing to do it.
And the death of Ruth Bader Ginsburg tragic
and may lead to one of the most conservative
supreme courts in decades.
But it seems to have increased enthusiasm
on the left.
Donations to Democrats have been pouring in
since the past passing of Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
And if anything like this happens when you
are voting, I want to hear about it.
If you can safely take video.
Take video and get it to me.
We will be talking about the voter intimidation
that takes place.
Keep an eye out and let me know what you see